the Apple silicon Mac Pro is coming and
I think it's coming next month at
Apple's March event because we just got
the biggest leaks ever pointing to a
March event launch and this is going to
be insane because we got even more leaks
of what is going to be packed into this
thing and it's better than I could ever
imagine and I'm gonna explain why but
first I've got to go through why I
thought this would be such a
disappointing upgrade now first of all
Apple missed their two-year timeline
which meant that the Mac Pro was
supposed to come in November of last
year but they totally missed but now it
looks like it's coming next month now
the reason why I thought it would be so
disappointing was that Mark gurman the
most accurate Apple leaker out there
said that the new Mac Pro would look
identical to the current model which was
kind of expected because it's easy for
Apple to do just reuse the same chassis
however they said that it would lack
expandable Ram yes the Mac Pro that's
supposed to be upgradable modular the
most customizable Mac you can get is not
going to have user replaceable Ram so
that is extremely disappointing it means
that the ram the memory is going to be
on the actual SOC chip just like the
other Apple silicon Max now that Lee
completely crushed my dreams because
imagine boo actually way back in March
of last year he said that it would
actually be possible to have external
RAM up to one terabyte and here's a
chart of how it could potentially work
however he did say that the external
memory controller was very very slow in
terms of access times even slower than
the older Xeon so the Apple memory team
was working on a solution for that but
it looks like based on what Mark German
said that failed they're not going to
have user replaceable Ram but then it
got even worse on January 25th Mark
Goodman came out and said that the next
Mac Pro o is also going to lack user
upgradable gpus in addition to
non-upgradable Ram so basically you
would be stuck with whatever
configuration you would have when you
buy it just like the Mac Studio the Mac
Mini all the regular Apple silicon Macs
no upgrade ability in terms of the Ram
or the graphics so essentially that
leaves the storage as the only user
upgradable component in the new Mac Pro
which would be a massive fail it would
basically be like a huge Max studio with
a bunch of PCI Express slots for audio
cards whatever custom cards that people
would need professionals would need that
is just so disappointing to not have
upgradable gpus or RAM and then we got
this an absolute nuclear bomb of a leak
from nine to five Mac exclusive iOS 16.4
code references new compute module
device
in the Mac Pro so basically the compute
module is a brand new device class that
runs iOS or a variant of it and there
would be at least two of them which is
the compute module 13 1 and 13 3. so in
two different models which to me kind of
sounds like M2 Max and M2 Ultra so what
it basically sounds like is a custom
Apple GPU that you slot in with an M2
Max ship with a bunch of GPU cores to
improve your graphics performance but
there is a catch which kind of makes
that not as good which I'll explain
later on in the video but the main
takeaway from this leak is that it's
connected to iOS 16.4 now if you didn't
already know Apple usually has a huge
mid-cycle software update that they
release in the springtime so iOS Mac OS
basically all the main software is
released in spring and many times it's
right after they have a March event and
release new products that come with that
new software so this points to the Mac
Pro coming in spring right after their
March event and adding further evidence
to this idea Apple also filed a new Mac
devices running Bluetooth 5.3 amid the
rumors of a new Macbook Air and Mac Pro
so everything is kind of lining up
perfectly for this Mac Pro to launch and
also we just had the M2 Max and M2 Pro
MacBook Pros launch back in January so
it would be perfect for the Mac Pro to
launch in the spring but now getting
back to the whole compute module leak I
think this could be even better than
just a GPU that you slot in and I
actually have two different scenarios
scenario one is of course the slottable
GPU card that you plug again for extra
raw GP performance but option two is
even better but before I explain I've
got to talk about a sponsor pulse way
imagine this all of your systems in one
central place no need for multiple
platforms to Monitor and manage your
systems when you can get pulse way an
all-in-one it monitoring and management
platform whether you're out getting
groceries taking the dock for a walk or
just don't want to get out of bed
pulseway's mobile app keeps you
connected monitor all of your systems
send commands apply patches remote
control troubled systems or manage
access it's really the only platform
you'll need their customizable patch
management policies are going to keep
your system safe and updated as you wish
create multi-level automation workflows
easily and start automating repetitive
tasks giving you your time back with
more time saved you can get back to
doing the things you love poolsway makes
it all possible get organized and take
control of your systems with pulse ways
industry-leading it management platform
the best of all is that you can try it
all for free get a 14-day trial when you
use the link in the description below
now getting back to the new leaked
compute modules in the Mac Pro I want to
start off with that second awesome
scenario and I want to refer to a tweet
from Jeff Benjamin which he posted at
basically the same time actually a
little bit earlier than I did but here
is a great idea let's say that you have
a new Apple silicon Mac Pro in the same
2019 Mac Pro case but with multiple
swappable brains yes the brain is
basically like he said the system on
package no need for networking storage
Etc on the actual brain card that way
you can have the fastest Mac Pro with
every single upgrade each M series
iteration if you pay for a new module so
essentially when the new map Pro comes
out you're gonna buy the new Apple
silicon Mac Pro chassis and you're going
to be able to choose your module that
plugs in so whether it's an M2 Max or an
M2 Ultra you choose it and it comes
completely done now in the future let's
say a couple years down the road few
years down the road a new M3 Ultra or M3
extreme M4 Ultra and four extreme comes
out and you purchase the module by
itself then you're gonna take out your
M2 module then plug in the new one and
there you go you just upgraded your
entire system now the actual Mac Pro
itself or on the inside you're gonna
have your power supply that remains
there the cooling system you're gonna
have the main motherboard which is
actually not the main motherboard it's a
daughter board or a secondary board
that's on the Mac Pro itself it's gonna
house the upgradable storage and
everything else that you need with the
PCI Express slots but the actual brain
of the machine is on the compu card
itself so this idea is insane because
you're only buying the main chassis once
and you upgrade the brains that is the
most modular machine that you can get
and professionals are gonna love this
now this idea basically has a potential
to make the Mac Pro upgradeable and
Timeless with apple silicon and that
would be a game changer in the industry
now I know you're probably going to say
that that sounds nuts it's insane
there's no way they can fit it well if
you look at the current Mac Pro and how
large the current GPU models are they
are absolutely massive and I would go as
far as to say that these Mac Pro GPU
cards that are available right now are
larger in volume than the actual Mac
Studio and the entire Mac Studio which
includes the motherboard the ssds the
huge cooling fan all of of that stuff is
smaller than these current Mac Pro cards
now the cool thing is that if you don't
need a lot of Graphics you can instead
buy a compute module that's focused on
having maximized CPU performance without
all of the GPU upgrades and cores that
you don't need now I know some of you
gonna say that this is not like apple
they're not going to allow you to go the
cheap route by just upgrading the brains
itself they want you to buy the whole
computer and yes Apple can actually do
this as well because if Apple wants to
sell more of the Mac Pro chassis then
when the time comes they could just
release a new chassis that has certain
upgrades like let's say a new more
efficient better power supply or better
fans maybe a new black color in terms of
the Finish or maybe some new extra ports
on the chassis itself or better yet
let's say the new chassis supports
Thunderbolt 5 on those case ports and
you want them so that's why people would
be buying the new chassis upgrades as
well because otherwise you're not going
to be able to take advantage of
Thunderbolt 5 on those case ports now to
me all of that sounds absolutely amazing
you're getting a fully upgradable Mac
Pro chassis with brains that you keep
swapping out but there's somebody else
hishnash on Twitter that completely
disagrees because he says that these
compute modules are running iOS 16.4
which means that they're very similar to
the studio display which has an iPhone
chip built in running iOS kind of for
all of the connection and Main thinking
that the display has to do to perform as
good as it does it handles all of that
so he is saying that the Mac Pro compute
modules will actually just have the
regular M2 Ultra or M2 Max or whatever
they call it and kind of an assistant
iOS chip running some kind of version or
kernel of iOS and that of course brings
us to the other scenario where these
compute modules are simply additional
custom apple gpus with some kind of
other chip name now of course I didn't
think this would happen because when
you're slotting in an additional card
it's not fully taking advantage of
unified memory because you're going to
have your M2 Ultra chip on the main
motherboard and then a separate card so
everything is not happening within the
same package so you're losing efficiency
but it could still happen for the tasks
that really need heavy raw GPU
performance like 3D rendering in blender
for example but if Apple does this it
would make it really easy for people to
purchase an additional one or two custom
GPU cards to slot in and get a huge
boost in terms of graphics performance
and with that said it would also make it
extremely expensive like Hachi the otter
says here we're gonna have a 55 000
Apple silicon machine no problem
hishnash even thinks it might even be
80k by adding a bunch of these compute
modules inside of the Mac Pro and then
making it even more likely Benjamin on
Twitter said that the Mac Pro with pcle
GPU is confirmed according to a new
patent which he showed right here
apparently this shows that apple is
working on getting these GPU module
cards working with an apple silicon Mac
so with that said those were the two
scenarios with the whole brains compute
module upgradeable everything packed in
so that's that so with that said those
were the two scenarios the first one
very simple just custom Apple GPU card
that slots in or the second one where
the entire brains is on the card itself
running the Mac Pro easy to upgrade let
me know what you think down in the
comment section below and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign